[Music]
nBC has suspended Today Show anchor
Billy Bush indefinitely following the
leak of previously unreleased audio of
the hosts engaging in conversation with
Donald Trump back in 2005 in it Donald
and Bush both made controversial
comments regarding women on Sunday night
NBC boss has decided he would not get
the opportunity to apologize at all he
would be suspended and we don't even
know for how long it's very possible
he'll never be back on the Today Show
here's how today addressed the
suspension on air Monday we want to note
one other thing pending further review
of the matter NBC News has suspended
Billy Bush the host of today's 3rd hour
for his role in that conversation with
Donald Trump
as you can see Billy Bush not joining us
today as you're probably aware part of
that 2005 Access Hollywood taping with
Donald Trump that's been in the news all
weekend in DC which owns Access
Hollywood has suspended Billy for his
role in that conversation pending
further review with that said it's
turned to last night's debate
entertainment tonight's Nancy O'Dell was
one of the women discussed in that 2005
tape tune into et on TV Monday to hear
what she has to say about the
controversy
[Music]
you